plantas y piedras son la fuente de
sanación que usa Franklin columba el
líder indígena aquí tu cara para
practicar la medicina tradicional andina
preservar sus conocimientos ancestrales
que no son reconocidos por el estado es
parte de lo que espera se llegue a un
acuerdo en la mesa de negociación con el
gobierno que se ha instalado Por 90 días
y por lo tanto en esta mesa de diálogo
lo que nosotros queremos es que a más de
respetar los derechos colectivos el
estado se comprometa a implementar
recursos para qué para que podamos
llegar a la profundización de la
investigación de nuestras prácticas
médicas tradicionales ancestrales esto
se pone aquí así Leonor es otra indígena
aquí tu cara pide la práctica artesanal
sedazo una técnica de tejido con la cola
de caballo como microempresaria también
se manifestó por el costo de la vida y
no es muy optimista sobre los acuerdos
que adelantan el gobierno y la cunaye
que el señor presidente no sabe cómo la
gente cómo el pueblo Cómo son las
necesidades de los pueblos suben una
cosa suben otra cosa y no hay plata que
alcance entonces por eso nosotros
salimos a la lucha y hemos de seguir
saliendo Si es que el señor presidente
no entra un diálogo tal vez hemos de
seguir saliendo durante 90 días el
gobierno ecuatoriano Se comprometió a
solucionar las peticiones indígenas en
10 mesas de diálogos tras 18 días de
protestas que paralizaron el país
Francisco Jiménez es el ministro de
gobierno encargado del diálogo sin
embargo la cuna y exige discutir cara a
cara con el presidente de la república
Guillermo lasso con el firme propósito
de ir afrontando los temas que más
preocupan al país y sobre todo a grandes
sectores de la población que durante
mucho tiempo permanecieron relegados Eso
no solamente significa una buena
intención
Eso significa también una voluntad de
solucionar los problemas hoy por hoy
problemas que Franklin discute a diario
en Asamblea comunitarias donde ponen en
duda la palabra del presidente de la
república con el acta de paz firmada
entre las partes